what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some
major loki spoilers and of course these
spoilers are for
the finale since there is only one
episode left coming in just a few days
now
and what's very interesting is that this
spoiler is coming from
none other than marvel studios not sure
if it was on purpose it certainly did
seem like it was very intentional
but it is a pretty big spoiler and it
actually kind of gives us a hint
towards who the main villain could be in
the final episode
who is in that castle i think today's
spoiler points to a pretty big theory
and that's what we're going to dive into
but of course obviously since i've
talked so much about a spoiler here is
your spoiler
warning if you don't want anything
spoiled for the finale of loki you
should click away now
also be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to stay up
to date on all things relating to the
mcu
so the reason i said i don't know if
this was intentional or not
is because it is coming from marvel
studios but it's coming from marvel
studios canada their official twitter
account
and they did a three-part tweet and it
said ladies and gentlemen
the loki's see them all in the fifth
episode of marvel studios says loki now
streaming on disney plus
ca which of course is disney plus canada
however this is the big reveal
in the first one they posted a picture
of the loki's that we saw last episode
bose foloki kid loki alligator loki
classic loki
president loki and all the other loki's
with him and of course arloki
then in the second one they again posted
boastful loki classic loki
kid loki alligator loki and arloki
however
in the third one they posted a picture
of alligator loki
boastful loki and hunter b-15
giving us the major spoiler that hunter
b-15
is actually a loki now before people
start to say that she looks absolutely
nothing like loki well
neither does boastful loki and he's a
confirmed loki
and hunter b15 would be the second
female variant of loki that we've seen
in the series but this implies that
she's going to have
a way bigger role than we thought she
was going to have in the finale
at least get her time to shine when she
figures out that she is indeed a loki
variant
or perhaps she already has sort of
figured it out silvie did awaken
memories inside of her in which she said
she looked happy could she have looked
happy being an asgardian princess
sylvie was a princess in asgard so we
could probably assume that hunter b15's
loki variant was a princess
as well so of course she looked happy
she had a father a mother who loved her
she had a brother
thor the god of thunder she lived in a
palace and was a princess
however the tva made it very clear that
there was not supposed to be
a female loki variant however when
sylvie was talking about the universe
and chaos in one of the episodes she
said that the universe is what brought
about
her the female loki variant so we can
assume that the same thing
happened with loki variant hunter b15
the universe spat out another female
loki variant and eventually the tva came
because that was not supposed to happen
if there isn't a loki that's going on to
die by the hands of thanos in avengers
infinity war that variant has to be
arrested and it seems like that loki has
to be male
as well which is another reason that
hunter b15 would have been taken in like
sylvie as well
now i hope hunter b15 gets her time to
shine when she realizes that she's a
loki and perhaps goes on to help sylvia
narloki
more than likely mobius will break her
out in episode 5 mobius went back to the
tva
since ren slayer and the other tva
agents are the ones that pruned him and
sent him away to the limbo world they're
more than likely
going to try and do it again so mobius
is going to need some help and hunter
b15 is his best option
not to mention she's probably the only
one inside of the tva that would be his
actual ally
so i think she'll get her time to shine
however what i want to talk about
is what this reveal actually means for
the main villain
this actually points me more in the
direction of
loki being the main villain not our loki
but perhaps a
king loki now just to clarify this does
not mean that i do not
think kang is behind it because i still
do but as far as
who is in that castle i think it could
be another variant of loki perhaps maybe
the first
variant there ever was like classic loki
said
their loki's they survive sylvie got
away from the tva as a child we could
assume that other loki's have gotten
away as well and i think one of them
could have actually taken over the tva
classic loki showed us that loki's are a
lot more powerful than
not only we realize but sometimes they
realize and after all it
is in loki's nature to control and
taking over the tva
is a loki move with the exception of
sylvie but are loki that was his plan he
wanted to take over the tva
but perhaps another loki beat him to it
perhaps there were actually time keepers
and another loki simply killed them and
the reason i think hunter b15 being a
loki variant points to a loki
being the main villain is because this
show loki is obviously all about loki
but with surprise variants happening i
think the move
based on what we know so far on marvel's
behalf and the writer's behalf is to
make loki the villain as well
he's the hero he's the anti-hero he's
the side characters and
he's the villain so i think king loki
could actually be the person inside of
that castle
now i don't think rin slayer knows this
i think she knows that perhaps the
timekeepers aren't real
that there's somebody else in charge
however she might be in the dark
on loki being in charge due to her
romantic relationship with
kang the conqueror in the comics i do
believe that she is working with
some variant of kang especially after
that huge kang easter egg in the last
episode where we saw
the avengers tower or the stark tower
and it had q-e
and g on the side which is the company
that nathaniel richards aka
kang the conqueror owns i think there
have been way too many easter eggs for
king not to be involved
in some way shape or form especially if
you consider that
jonathan majors is confirmed to be
playing kang in ant-man and the wasp
in phase four so i think loki could be
kang's setup however i don't think he's
going to be the main
villain of the series i think it would
be a lot to just throw him
in randomly in the third episode for
those non-super comic book fans like us
that do research so i think going the
direction of
a loki variant himself being the main
villain is the direction that marvel
marvel's going to go however i do think
that kang is in the background
trying to make a move and i think that
rin slayer is actually working with him
which is why rin slayer actually does
want to find out who is in charge of the
tva
so she can take out that person for kang
or report back to kang and kang can go
take out that person and i think that
person is loki
based off of what we know and all of the
images from the trailers that we haven't
seen yet
there is some sort of asgardian king
loki that we are going to see
now some people are thinking that these
could be flashbacks and yes they could
but they're not going to be flashbacks
of our loki because
our loki has never been king of asgard
the scenes that we see
of king loki have never happened for r
loki so if they are indeed flashbacks
they are
flashbacks of another loki which would
be
the villain or perhaps these aren't
flashbacks at all perhaps
inside of that castle is indeed loki and
he's created an
asgard inside of the castle using his
powers of illusion
if a loki variant truly is in charge of
the tva he's obviously
extremely powerful probably more
powerful than classic loki and we saw
how powerful he was we saw
how strong his illusions were he created
asgard
the entirety of asgard so we can
probably assume that
king loki is pretty powerful as well and
could create an asgard inside of that
castle and that is most likely what
we're seeing
but we don't have much longer to wait to
find out and i do
think kang could be coming in a
post-credits scene for the loki finale
because again i just think there have
been way too many easter eggs for king
not to be in this somehow but be sure to
let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below what do you
think about hunter b15 being a loki
variant
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof